So,
um,
I wanted to take another look at this
figure to begin with.
No,
what are the reasons that I
began to think about these sorts of
things just because I wanted to
understand what it might mean to have a
set of,
let's say,
a set of values and beliefs because
those two things go together.
That would,
I guess part of the question was,
is it possible to develop a system of
belief that's outside of the realm of
videology no,
because one thing you might claim is
that,
yeah,
it's all ideology and belief system is,
it is ideological and if you develop a
belief system that criticizes other
belief systems,
it just means that you've developed a
new ideological stance and there's some.
That's a good argument.
You know,
I can think of a number of ways that
it's true.
One of the things neat you said in the
late 18 hundreds was that if you
inhabited the belief system,
even a religious system and you lost
faith in it,
not only did you lose faith in that
system,
but you also potentially lost faith in
systems themselves.
And so it was a medical apps in a sense,
not only did you lose your belief,
but you lost your belief in belief so
you can think of the set of all possible
beliefs and then abandoning any hope of
relying on noses,
valid sources of information
so
you know,
so that's one perspective and it's a,
it's a powerful one and we need you to
believe that that was a certain pathway
denialism essentially,
or perhaps to a reactionary
totalitarianism,
but it boils down to the same thing.
I'd been reading this book
recently,
which the title of,
I can't remember unfortunately,
but I'll tell it to you after class.
It's a.
it's a critique of certain lines of left
wing ideological thinking,
including the existential thought.
If people like John Paul Sartre and food
co and one of the most trenchant
critiques of Sartre because he believes
that you sort of have an absolute
freedom that you're destined for freedom
that you're doing to it.
In some sense,
part of your existential
journey is to establish an authenticity.
That's correct for you,
but he doesn't.
He isn't able really to give any
description of what that should be
grounded in and the critic
concludes that all Sartre can do is
stand outside of any potential belief
system and criticize it and that that's,
there's nothing in it for anyone as a
consequence of that.
It's,
it's only destructive now.
It's important to remember with regards
to Sartre that he viewed other people to
some degree,
like the common man,
the bourgeoisie we might say as the
embodiment of non freedom of
inauthenticity and also as a barrier to
genuine authenticity so he wasn't
willing to give any credence to the
utility of normality,
but I also think he wasn't able to
tolerate the consequences of his own
thought because he was a avid supporter
of the communist party far after anyone
with any reasonable moral sense would
have stopped doing that.
So sergeant really didn't denounce the
communists until the end of the
beginning of the seventies.
Roughly speaking.
It was never a card carrying communist,
but he was a very.
It was very left leaning and you know,
by,
by the 19 seventies,
by the late sixties,
by the,
by the early seventies,
a lot of the evidence about what was
going on in Soviet Russia had been in
for 30 years.
So there is really no excuse for not
facing up to that and trying to
understand what it meant and it would be
bad enough if it was just Soviet Union,
but it wasn't the same sort of thing
happened.
Wherever those utopian pre a precept
positions were put into place.
And I suppose many of you don't know
this,
but Paul Paul,
who was the Cambodian dictator,
was educated at this sort of bomb.
And he wrote his thesis on the.
He wrote his,
I think it was his phd thesis,
although it might've been his master's
thesis on the Marxist doctrine that the,
that uh,
urban people were parasites on rural
people.
So you know,
there's a theory that says that the
genuine value this is generated purely
by labor and much of that rural labor
and the city's siphon off the excess
productive power and are able to Paris
the ties,
the countryside as a consequence of that
and which is an,
you know,
tremendously
nonproductive theory,
but Pol Pot put it into practice.
And so when he went back into Cambodia,
he chased everybody out of the cities
and killed about 6 million people.
So,
you know,
you can read about that if you want.
It's a pretty appalling section of,
of 20th century history,
you know,
especially when it's the case that he
was in.
He was educated in the west and had
these presuppositions drummed into them.
And then there's fruit,
Cole Cole,
who I have no respect for it by the way
I think.
I think I've read a fair bit of foot
cool.
And I think everything he says is
obvious.
So for example,
he criticizes the idea of mental illness
as a,
as a social construct.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
obviously,
I mean it's not like psychiatrists and
psychologists and mental health
professionals who are relatively well
informed,
haven't known about that since for the
last 60 years.
I mean it might be a revelation to
people who who don't notice that psyche
psychiatry for example,
is something like a compromise between
the patient biology and the social
world.
You know what I mean?
Psychiatric ailments often have a
biological tilt,
but the way they manifest themselves in
society is clearly conditioned in very
intense ways by the particular
conditions.
Obtaining at the point that the person
who has that biological predisposition
exists even whether or not that's
pathological can be tilted one way or
another by the by cultural norms and
then of course when you're dealing with
issues like insurance,
payment and treatment and
hospitalization,
obviously you're pulling in all sorts of
systems that are by no means purely
scientific,
but I don't find it particularly useful
critique.
It's obvious as far as I'm concerned,
and the other thing that code did,
I mean I think this is the typical,
especially the French intellectuals,
typical sleight of hand.
Once Marxism became,
you know,
once you were no longer able to call
yourself a committed Marxist because
committed Marxism had led to
unbelievable brutality,
you know,
on a scale that had never probably,
I think never been experienced in the
entire history of the planet,
at least in terms of its reach and
duration.
You didn't get to call yourself a
Marxist anymore,
although there were still people and you
still see them saying,
well,
that wasn't real Marxism.
Which I think is a combo of staggering
proportions.
That usually means,
well,
if I was the person running the country,
that wouldn't have happened.
You know,
that's the logic behind it.
They didn't put the principles into
practice properly.
It's like,
yeah,
well lots of people put the damn
principles into practice and the same
thing happened everywhere.
So at some point you have to kind of
wonder if there's something wrong with
the principals.
Anyways,
what I did was take the Marxist
presupposition that everything was,
could be boiled down to economics and
economic power and translated it into
the idea that everything just boiled
down to power.
You know,
and the reason that we have institutions
is to include and to exclude and that
the institutions always run for the
benefit of those at the top.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's a little bit true,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's a scientist would look at that and
say,
yeah,
well probably,
you know,
power dynamics in a,
in a functioning economic and political
system,
maybe account for 10 percent of the
variance,
something like that,
maybe 15 percent.
So for example,
if you have a say you want to go to an
ivy league school,
while if your parents went to the
school,
you're more likely to get in,
but you're not that much more likely to
get in and you still have to be,
you know,
roughly speaking,
what happens is that if you have a
pretty decent,
you know,
high school gpa and you do very well on
the sats and you have some other talents
of some sort because that's also
necessary,
then they might pick you over someone
else who's roughly will you qualify it.
If you have a familial history of
attendance at school.
So obviously you get an exact end an
advantage,
but it's not.
It's not the kind of advantage that
accounts for the entirety of how the
system is structured.
It's an advantage.
While you can say,
well that's not fair.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
Most systems are certainly not 100
percent either.
Fair or just definitely not,
but you know,
instead of comparing them to utopia,
you might compare them to another
system,
which is the only reasonable way to do
it.
It's like everything looks terrible when
you compare it to the best thing you can
possibly imagine,
but the best thing you can possibly
imagine is it's an empty fiction because
it's so devoid of detailed content that
you can't use it as a guide to reality.
Now,
I mean the idea that things could be
better has its roots in some sense in a
broad scale Utopian project and I
believe that things could be better,
but that doesn't mean that when you're
doing an analysis of a complex system,
you get to compare it to an ideological
utopia and then describe all the reasons
that it's bad.
It's not
appropriate to do that.
It's too simplistic.
You're not going to do anything to
actually address the problems that the
system has.
If you take that approach.
And then of course like pure utopian
thinking is extraordinarily dangerous
because if you think that your way of
molding society into some ultimate state
of perfection is headed towards some
ultimate state of perfection,
then you can justify absolutely anything
you do right now on the basis of the
fact that things are going to improve so
radically in the future.
And that means any of your behaviors are
excused.
The end is worth it.
Well,
if someone says that you have to kind of
wonder what there are actually planning.
Oh,
excuse me,
what they're actually planning to do.
So.
Okay,
so,
well,
what's the issue?
Well,
the is that it's
so the same critic with regards to Food
Co.
He said,
you know what's basically the same thing
that food,
coal criticized a variety of low,
you know,
profound institutions,
sexual institutions say like marriage
and then institutions of power like
prisons and institutions of,
um,
mental health,
you know,
the whole institutional framework.
He criticized them on the basis of power
and exclusion and you could do that and
there's some truth in it,
but you know,
food,
coal also made the presupposition.
The problem with that presupposition is
that everything is about something else
is that it's almost impossible to see
how it can be applied to fukiko himself.
So you'd have to ask if you were a
student of flute coal,
what power aims drove his attempt to
analyze everything in terms of power.
and I actually think with code it's
pretty obvious.
So,
but it's a game that never goes
anywhere.
Okay.
So I thought about that a lot is like is
there any system that you can develop
that doesn't have the negative
consequences of systems in general and
then if that is possible,
how and why might it be possible?
And this is partly why I'm talking to
you about this particular diagram again,
and I think the reason now I don't know
this and you guys can think it through
yourself.
I mean,
lots of people have talked to me about
the content of this course and you know,
they've said that it's been very helpful
for them when it comes to interpreting
certain elements of their life,
you know,
but some people have said,
well,
it's just another system and
I don't believe that.
I think it's a medical system and I
don't think the rules that apply to
systems also apply to medical systems,
but you know,
that could just be me.
So you,
you're going to have to decide that for
yourself.
But I think the reason that I can make
that claim and that it's a valid claim
is because first of all,
I don't believe it's an intellectual
system.
I don't think it's an attempt to reduce
a complex set of phenomena to something
that is
what dispenses with important elements
of their,
of their existence.
So for example,
let me give you an example of how that
sort of thing happens.
Like if you're looking at the world
through a biased lands,
what it means is you take nonrandom
samples of the environmental data.
So I can give you a quick example of
something I saw that I thought was very
particular in that regard.
I don't think I've used this example
before,
but about 10 years ago or there abouts,
naomi klein made a documentary about
this factory down in south America,
I believe it was in Argentina and this
was just after all the foreign capital
fled to Argentina and the economy
collapsed completely,
which is something that happens to
Argentina fairly regularly by the way.
And she went down there to this factory
where there were working man,
um,
and they had been building heavy
machinery and the working men decided
that they were going to.
This factory had been padlocked and they
had been locked out because things had
come to a halt and they decided that
they were going to take the chains off
the factory gate and go in there and
start making heavy machinery again.
You know,
it's a very cool documentary as far as I
was concerned.
She went down there and she interviewed
all these working guys and you know,
they talked about how their lives have
been brought to a halt by the factory
closure and and obviously it sucked that
they were sitting around doing nothing
and not being paid for anything when
they could have been inside the factory
building heavy machinery,
which is what they wanted to do.
So she went down there and laid out
their story and it was very sympathetic
to the workers and good,
you know,
fair enough,
good.
But then she went and interviewed the
guy who owned the factory and she didn't
ask him any real questions,
you know,
because what she had she did instead was
caricaturizing him.
even a priority is sort of,
you know,
a fascist,
a capitalist,
sort of like the millionaire in a
monopoly and,
and never tried to get beneath the
superficial a priority categorization to
find out what the hell he actually
thought.
And I was just waiting.
I thought,
okay,
well this is cool.
What the hell does the factory owner
have to say?
It's like,
where does money go?
why does he think he has a right to the
factory?
Like what are his conditions of
ownership?
Did he earn the money with video
inherited?
It's like,
what does he think about the fact that
Argentina is gone to me is collapsed?
What does he.
How does he feel about the fact that all
these workers are out of work?
What does he think about the fact that
they opened up the factory again,
like there's a lot of interesting things
to ask this guy.
None of them,
none of it had.
And so to me what happened was that she
was like someone with neglect,
you know,
where she was looking at the world,
but you could only see half of
everything and the half she saw was
probably perfectly no justifiable had
it's had its proper domain of
application,
but the half she missed.
it's like,
well what about that part of the story?
You're going to reduce that to.
You're going to reduce that too cliche
and stereotype and expand up the rest of
the story.
Well,
the only reason you do that is if you
didn't want to find out what the hell
was going on.
If you all wanted to do is gather
evidence that would support your initial
theory.
No,
I know perfectly well that there's
plenty of situations where workers,
the conditions of workers are absolutely
abysmal.
I mean,
one of the books I've read this I think
are remarkable documentation of that
fact is a book by george orwell called
road to wigan pier,
which is a study of the conditions that
coal miners lived in in 19 thirties in,
in,
in britain,
and you know,
it's bloody dismal.
One,
the idea that they were exploited,
it's.
Well that's a tougher one because
the industrial revolution was very,
very hard on people and it was really,
really hard on some people,
you know,
particularly on some people,
whether that was because of exploitation
or because of the existence of absolute
poverty is not all that obvious and you
know,
so it's a complicated.
It's a complicated issue now.
There's lots of times when workers were
clearly exploited,
but I think there were times as well
when they work anyways.
It's a great book and you know,
he does a lovely job of laying out a
rationale for why the workers should be
treated far better than they were
treated and so fine.
Good.
Wonderful.
There's something to be said,
but the thing is when you want to say
something,
you want to take an unbiased sample if
you can.
And so this is why I like this
particular motive conceptualization and
I think it's the reason I think it's not
an intellectual construction is because
I think it emerges naturally out of the
structure of mythology and narrative and
you can think this through yourself,
but as far as I've been able to tell
narratives that present themselves in
terms of archetypal characters.
And the thing about a comprehensive
narrative is it can't leave out an
archetypal character or it failed.
Now I can give you an example of this.
Okay?
So how many of you have seen disney
sleeping beauty?
Okay.
So,
so many of you have.
How many it.
Okay,
so,
so there's a few that happened while the
disney movies,
you know,
they're kind of standard childhood
affairs now in sleeping beauty.
What happens is that the king and queen
give birth to a princess after trying
for a substantial amount of time and you
know,
she arrives healthy and beautiful and
then they have a christening day and
they invite everybody to it,
but they don't invite maleficent who's a
dark,
which roughly speaking,
you know,
like she's,
uh,
she's queen of the underworld that for,
for lack of a better word,
she's the negative element of femininity
and they don't invite her to the party.
And so she shows up anyways and says
that because they didn't invite her,
um,
their daughter's going to die when,
when she had 16,
which is roughly the age of let's say,
sexual maturation for a story of that
sort.
Now there's another little positive
magic female in the story who mitigates
that death sentence to protracted sleep.
While the idea behind it,
it's a very,
very interesting story.
It's an incredible story in a sense
because what it says is that if your
parents protect you too much from the
dark side of life when you're young,
that what will happen when you start to
on the road to maturity is you'll be so
naive and so fragile that you'll want to
be unconscious instead of paying
attention and that you're going to have
to be rescued from that state by
something and it could be a prince,
which is one which is how that story
lays itself out.
Or it also could be that symbolically
masculine and exploratory element of
your own psyche and the stories are
ambivalent about whether it's an
external event or an intern with and it
doesn't really matter.
You know,
the,
the things ended up being the same.
And so that's actually what happens in
this,
in the sleeping beauty story.
You know,
at the end,
prince who's also enslaved by this
terrible negative feminine force manages
to escape.
And the maleficent turns into a dragon
and he has to fight her.
And then he goes and rescues the
princess and she wakes up and the
kingdoms rejuvenated.
And everybody's happy.
It's a classic classic story,
you know,
and it's not.
It's funny because tHe disney movie
frozen was put forward as a,
in some sense,
as a feminist alternative to the classic
fairytales at first of all,
you can't do that.
You can't just generate up a fairytale.
You know,
there's recent evidence that some of
these fairytales,
the ones that the grimm brothers and the
and hans christian andersen collected
are up to 10,000 years old.
You can't just come up with a counter
fairy tale.
That's just not how it works.
And the way that fairytale is
structured,
it has nothing to do with,
with the necessity for anyone to rely on
anyone else for anything.
It's a complex portrayal of the denied
dynamic relationship between archetypal
characters.
And you know,
it's one form of the story.
There's lots of different forms of the
story.
But what I liked about sleeping beauty
for example,
and mrs,
what's nice about the real fairytales is
that along with the positive,
there is negative and it's real
negative.
Like real fairy tales are terrified.
Like I don't who is it?
Is it in sleeping beauty or in snow
white?
I don't remember.
In one of the famous grimm fairy tales,
one of the evil sisters ends up dancing
and red hot shoes until she dies.
You know,
it's,
they're very,
very violent and and unsettling,
and it's because they,
you know,
they have the quality of genuine folk
tales,
but the reason for that is because
they're dealing with real things like
the hansel and gretel is a good example
of that,
right?
Kids are abandoned out in the woods.
They find something that's too good to
be true inside this thing that's too
good to be true is something that wants
to fatten them up and devour them.
It's a rough story,
but what it's doing,
the stories,
the stories have evolved to represent
the fundamental dynamic elements of
existence.
If you conceptualize existence in,
in,
in terms of character,
and the thing is you have to
conceptualize existence in terms of
character.
If you're a person because what you do
and existence is act out your character,
so your character is an element of
existence.
Now you might say,
well,
that doesn't mean that society has a
character,
but actually it does mean that because
partly what happens,
like if you're socialized,
say into a culture,
the culture exists in the same
relationship to you,
roughly speaking as another person does.
So for example,
if you put money in the bank,
which is in principle a representation
of your labor.
What you're doing is entering into a
contract with the broader social world,
which is one of promise essentially
where the future society promises to
return your value at a future date.
So it's a contractual relationship and
the reason that god,
the father is a very common
representation is because treating the
they in in heideggerian terms,
the others in heideggerian terms as if
they're an embodied entity actually
works.
So it's because it is an emergent
property of all over the personalities
that make it up and so you're.
You're interacting with that emergent
personality all the time.
You could even say,
for example,
that that's the friday and ied.
It's the thing that the representation
of that inside you is what makes you
feel guilty.
When you transgress against certain
moral rules and you might say along with
the radical existentialists that that's
just arbitrary and that you can create
your own values,
but it's not just arbitrary because it's
dependent on the consent of others as
well as on some internal harmony or
disharmony.
It's not arbitrary and you can't just
set that up by yourself so you know
these things or these things are
realities and their deep realities.
Now this particular portrayal indicates
a kind of balance,
so the the fundamental ground of reality
is neither positive nor negative.
It's the ground out of which everything
positive or negative emergence.
So you might think of the fundamental
ground of reality as that which exists
prior to your encounter with it and we
have no idea what that is.
Now you can think about it as you can
think about it as
people tend to think about what things
are made of anatomic terms,
but it's not a particularly
comprehensive way of thinking about it
because what what exists beyond the
realm of your comprehension is the
pattern relationship between everything
and everything and you can't reduce it
to any simple level of analysis because
you miss all sorts of elements of it
that are extraordinarily important.
If you do that,
so you can't do that.
That's not what experiences made out of
you know,
or what the ground of experience is made
of it and so it's neutral in some sense
it because it exists beyond your
encounter with it.
It's the unknown as such,
and the reason that that's often
represented in the form of a predatory
lizard that has something to offer is
precisely because of that.
It's like the absolute unknown has the
capacity to tear you into pieces and
burn you up,
but it also has the possibility of
rewarding you with everything you could
possibly be rewarded with.
So it's this strange juxtaposition of
potential.
I'd like to think about it as potential,
you know,
because people can get a grip on what
potential means.
There's potential everywhere,
whatever that is.
You have full potential.
Your parents tell you that all the time.
What is that?
Well,
it's the unrealized stuff of your being.
Now.
It's a very strange concept,
potential because you can't characterize
it any way that you would characterize
something that's real because it's not
real.
It's potential,
but you act like it's real.
You know,
you'll feel guilty that you're not
living up to your potential.
You're not manifesting your potential.
You want people to interact with you so
that they allow you to demonstrate your
potential.
Like you act as if it's a reality.
Continually.
You Think as if it's a reality.
You ask if your relationship has
potential,
you know,
and,
but it's a very,
very strange substance.
Whatever this potential is,
it's the,
um,
it's unrealized possibility essentially,
but you regard it as something that's
fluid and something that can develop in
all sorts of different directions and
something whose development you can
shape because otherwise,
why would you feel guilty?
It's like,
you know,
if you're doing the wrong thing,
you're realizing some potential in the
wrong way and then you feel bad about
that.
It's like,
well there's,
there's some sense of intrinsic morality
operating at the bottom of that and
we've talked a lot about that.
some of that's built in biologically.
Some of it's,
you know,
structured culturally,
some of it's a consequence of you trying
to,
you know,
trying to organize your in this plethora
of semi beings that you are into some
integrated manner.
Like it's a very,
very complicated thing and it's not just
arbitrary.
Okay.
So that's the background,
the dragon of chaos,
positive and negative.
And it's,
it's the thing out of which everything
springs.
If you look at the scandinavian world
tree for example,
or world trees in general,
you very frequently have a
representation of a serpent that's
associated with the reason that the
potential is regarded as serpentine is
extraordinarily complicated.
but I think it's partly because say
snakes shed their own skin and so they
can be reborn.
So there are a symbol of transformation
and then they are sneaky and subtle and
so they appear in places you wouldn't
necessarily expect them to.
And then there were a terrible,
terrible threat.
But in overcoming that threat,
you also develop.
So not only are they a threat,
but they're the kind of threat that
makes you become strong.
Well,
you face it.
So that's partly why the snake is such
an ambivalent figuring in most
mythology.
So,
okay,
so that's complicated,
but we'll return to that later.
And then out of that you might say,
emerges the unknown as you encounter it.
So there's,
there's potential itself.
And then the first layer of potential
are the things that you encountered that
you don't understand.
So I can give you an example of that.
so let's say you're a three year old or
two year old,
that'll be,
that's better.
And you're in your kitchen and a mouse
rent across the room and so you track it
because you know your eyes pick up the
movement and you track the thing and
then it's,
it's an unexpected occurrence.
So you don't know what it signifies.
Right?
So that's the emergence of something
tangibly unknown into your conceptual
space.
Now it's not like you lacked any
knowledge of it.
You can tell that it what it sizes and
you can get some estimation of its
speed,
you know,
and I think that what you have to do
when you think about whether or not
something is unknown is you have to
think about it in relationship to that
hierarchy of perception that I keep
throwing at you.
You know,
if,
if something emerges,
if you encounter an entity and you can
map it at every single level of your
value hierarchy,
then it's known,
you know,
how to interact with it at a micro level
and you know what its implications are
for every other level of your conceptual
being.
You know,
what its implications are for the
future.
Like you know exactly how to deal with
that thing.
It's mapping at every single level.
There's other things that are only
mapped at one level and not others.
So maybe you know,
you like the model s we'll say For the
child who's never seen him.
I,
it's like it shares some commonalities
with objects that the child is familiar
with,
but there's sufficient novelty so that
it's also contaminated with the unknown
and that makes the child basically
alert,
semi startled and alert.
Now the child will immediately refer to
an adult.
It's a technical term actually.
They'll look at the adults face because
the adults face.
We'll broadcast the motivational and
affective significance of that event and
so child looks references and then reads
off the face of course the speech and
the bodily auctions.
Exactly what that thing signifies,
you know,
and,
and then if the person that they're
looking at jumps up on the table and
screams,
then that's one set of meanings,
which is god,
this thing is magical.
It'S only this big.
And look at what effect it has on,
you know,
my aunt for the sake of argument,
who's,
you know,
pretty confident preacher as far as I
can tell being two years old,
you know?
And then if she just dismisses it,
you know,
her actions are going to determine the
meaning of that phenomena.
So that's how the transformation of the
semi known thing into the more known
thing occurs,
occurs almost always in a social
context.
You can explore things by yourself,
but you rarely actually do that by
yourself.
It's almost always you plugged into a
social apparatus,
you know,
so you might be doing the specific
investigating,
but the social apparatus is around you
so that you can confer with it and it
also shapes the way that you're going to
interact with that specific thing.
Okay,
so
now the unknown.
That's generally not the unknown that
you encountered that generally
characterized
using feminine symbolism.
And I think the reason for that.
There's a bunch of reasons,
and we've talked about many of them.
One reason is because females do the
sexual selection in human beings and so
they act as the face of nature.
Another reason is,
is that you can think of new possibility
always emerging out of the non cultural
background in some sense.
You know.
So for example,
let's say that we send an expedition to
mars and we're gathering new
information.
As a consequence,
the reason we're gathering new
information is because we've gotten out
past the domain of our knowledge in a
sense and we're interacting with
something new and then that interaction,
new information is generated.
Now you can say that it's partly the act
of the perceiver that's generating the
new information and you can say that
it's partly the act of the culture
because we send robots to mars,
let's say,
which is very,
very difficult.
So the culture goes there,
but the individuals are observing,
so the individuals are buttressed by the
culture,
but they are generating information
because there's somewhere truly new and
so the information,
you know,
the unknown is a constant source of new
information.
So it's a place that gives birth to new
information and so that's another part
of the reason that it seems to be
symbolized in feminine form.
No,
I'm just taking this in some senses and
empirical fact I've looked at it looks
like that's how these stories work and
so I'd be trying to puzzle out why
exactly that would be the case.
You know?
I also think it's the case that we tend
to look at the world from a social
cognitive perspective,
right?
We filter it through a social,
cognitive,
biological apparatus,
and so we're very likely to see things
in character for him and characters have
sexes and so that's going to happen.
And then which the attributes of
femininity are the attributes of
masculinity that get used.
Symbolic reference in some sense there.
There's an arbitrary ness about it.
So for example,
for the egyptians,
you know,
usually you have a sky god,
but they had a sky goddess.
Now she generally represent the night
sky,
which is not exactly the same thing as
the day sky,
but you know,
you,
you have to.
It's so tricky because you have to look
at the relationships between the
characters in order to decide what all
of the mean.
And that shifts a little bit from story
to story.
So this is a,
what would you say?
It's an approximation of the underlying
structure,
but there's a fair bit of variance in
it.
Just like there's variation in stories
so.
Well,
the feminine element has a destructive
element and a creative ass aspect,
and you can see that people characterize
their environments in that way.
So for example,
you can map on environmental beliefs
onto this structure.
You can say that the environmentalist,
poor trays,
nature as positive,
portrays culture as negative and
portrays the individual is negative,
and the basic story is rampaging
individual as member of a rapacious
culture invading the pristine landscape
of,
of beautiful mother nature.
Now the thing about that story is it's
true.
The problem with this story is it's hAlf
true now.
So for example,
one thing that's interesting to
conceptualize is that that's exactly the
opposite of the frontier myth.
Now,
the frontier myth was a story that was
used extensIvely in europe to drive
immigration into the United States,
and it was used to some degree in Canada
too.
In this story was the exact opposite.
It's the hero.
So that would be the immigrant pioneer
bringing the benefits of order to a
savage wilderness.
Well,
that's also true,
but it's so interesting that both of
those things can be true and they're
completely different from one another.
There's no commonality at all between
those two stories except for the way
that they use the characters.
There's a feminine character of a
masculine character that represents
culture,
and then there's another character that
represents the individual and you could
even see that if you think about it
historically,
the us was founded in some sense on a
frontier myth and you know that was too
one sided,
and so by the time the 19 sixties came
along the early 19 sixties,
it's shifted to its opposite and that
you need that because
you like systems have to oscillate to
some degree to remain stable across
time.
They can't just be fixed in place,
so they're going to play back and forth
through the archetypes in an attempt to
keep them balanced because that's what
you're trying to do.
You're trying to keep them balanced and
so while you have the destructive and
creative element of mother nature,
you see that all the time in movies
where the,
the,
the thing that the hero is striving as
against is the negative element of the
unknown.
How many of you have Seen the movie
alien?
Okay,
so you know,
that's a pretty graphic representation
of,
well those aliens are more reptilian
informed so they're almost like there
are more at the dragon of chaos level
of,
of civilization,
but they're like a terrible external
force that's threatening human culture
and the individual.
It's the exactly the opposite story
that's played out in what was the movie
with all the blue creatures.
Avatar.
Avatar is exactly the opposite of that
where you know,
the,
the unknown nature is just nothing but
it's like sweetness and bliss and you
know,
and the,
and the human culture is portrayed as
spearheaded by greedy and rapacious
individuals who are basically
manifestations of the military
industrial complex.
And the funny thing is those both make
good stories and that's because,
well,
it's because they have enough archetipal
truth so that there's many situations
that they're relevant to.
You know,
sometimes mother nature is your best
friend and sometimes it's your worst
enemy.
SO you could go down to the jungles of
Peru and you could talk to the
people who lived there and you can find
out what they know about medicinal
plants in the jungle.
And you could bring home thingS to cure
dIsease or you could just go down there
and get lost in the jungle and then your
dad,
you know,
and in,
in some sense it's the same jungle and
whether it's positive or negative,
depends on what stance you take towards
it and how you behave.
And so the other thing that's really
interesting about mythology,
and this is the lovely element of
mythology,
is that part of what it does is tell you
how to take this incredibly complex
landscape that's positive and negative
at the same time,
at every level of analysis and how to
navigate through it so that the belt,
the proper balance is maintained as far
as really as far as the entire system is
concerned.
So,
so that culture has an orderly element
and that's what protects us here.
And it has a tyrannical element.
And that's what makes you treated like
numbers at the university of toronto.
You know,
you get both of those have exactly the
same time.
And then the architect will,
individual has the same fundamental
nature,
hero or villain.
And you know,
those,
those have archetypal roots because the
ultimate hero is the ultimate perfect
person and the ultimate villain is,
you know,
satan himself in whatever for me happens
to take,
you know,
and
it doesn't take much knowledge of this
structure before you can start seeing it
manifest itself all over,
especially especially movies that are
particularly popular because they almost
always have a central architectural
feat.
The marvel superhero movies are a really
good example of that.
So,
you know,
and if it's complex literature,
the architects are mixed to some degree.
So you have a hero who's not only a
hero,
you have a hero,
has all sorts of flaws,
you know,
had these in the culture or she's in a
culture that has positive elements and
negative elements that they're in a
broader landscape.
This characterized by exactly the same
thing.
So it's nuanced,
you know,
and the more sophisticated you get,
the more you can tolerate that kind of
nuance.
And I think that's also one of the
things that's partly why literature is
such a good antidote to radiology
because the more sophisticated the
literature becomes,
the more complex and fragmented in some
sense or no differentiated,
the more differentiated the
architectural landscape becomes.
So when someone tells you a story,
whatever the story happens to be,
one of the things you can do when you
know the substructures,
you can say,
okay,
yeah,
but where were the missing pieces?
Where are they going?
Because if they're not included and
they're generally projected onto
something because they're there,
you can't get away from there there.
How does the person account for them?
You know,
so.
All right.
So then now I want to tell you another
story.
So we talked about the mesopotamian
creation last can.
Now I want to tell you about the
egyptian myth of sovereignty.
And so the first thing I should do is
say that all of the stories that I'm
talking to you about have all sorts of
variance,
you know.
And so the,
the egyptian story that I'm going to
describe lasted for thousands and
thousands of years.
So it isn't like there was only one
variation of it,
there's all sorts of variations of it
and I'm only going to tell you one of
them and that's a limitation,
but that's just how it is for the time
being.
So I'm not saying that this is the only
version of this story,
but it's average in and it's the one I'm
most familiar with and so I can talk
about it hopefully with some utility and
it's a great story.
When I finally figured out what it
meant,
it's so cool with some of these stories,
like if you crack them and you're able
to see what they mean,
they're absolutely overwhelming.
There are so bloody brilliant.
It's just,
it's no wonder that people regard them
as revelatory,
you know,
of divine origin because they have such
power that it's almost impossible to
imagine how that got there.
Now I have provided you with a darwinian
explanation of how that got there,
right?
Because the stories are representations
of
social contracts and behavioral
tendencies that have evolved over
thousands and thousands of years.
Because of that,
the representation,
the story is going to have way more
information in it than a typical story
might,
but I still can understand how these
things burst upon people.
The force of revelation,
you know,
and one of the things that's quite
interesting too,
if you look at cultures historically is
that you usually find that the
revelation of the story,
it's like the energy source on which the
culture feeds.
So the story comes first.
It has this tremendous dynamic energy.
The culture basically uses that energy
to propel itself through time,
you know,
to give it conviction and force,
and then at some point the story
exhausts itself and that would be
equivalent in some sense,
I suppose,
to nietzsche's announcement of the death
of god.
And this has happened many times.
So.
All right,
so there's four main characters in the
egyptian story.
There's cyrus,
isis set and horace now.
Oh,
sarah's.
We'll start with those series.
but you could start with any of the
characters because one of the things
that's quite interesting about mythology
is that the myths don't make any
distinction between the causal priority
of these characters.
Any of them can be regarded as
fundamental,
so the hero is the person who separates
the world.
Parents,
for example,
it brings being into existence,
but you can also say,
well,
it's time math,
which is more how the mesopotamian
creation myth is tilted.
Or you can say,
well,
you can't make sense out of anything
unless you have a cultural lens through
which you're looking like you know,
there has to be some preexisting
structure before information can be
generated in any manner,
so you're always stuck with this problem
that in order for something to exist,
you need a substrate,
you need an interpretive structure and
you need an interpreter and that's.
And you can't say that one of those
things precedes the other there.
They all have to be there at the same
time.
You could say from a darwinian
perspective,
they all emerged and complexified in
unison like that.
As,
as you know,
as time progressed,
it doesn't explain how the origin of the
orange originated.
However,
okay,
so you've got to osiris now.
Osiris is the founder of the egyptian
state and so you know,
before people wrote things down,
you have to kind of try to understand
how it was that they remembered things
like they,
their memory was more like an amalgam or
adjust.
So we already know that,
you know,
if you tell the story of your,
of your actions yesterday,
that it doesn't take you 16 hours to
tell the story,
hopefully takes you like five minutes
and why that is,
it's not obvious,
but part of the reason is,
is that for whatever,
for whatever underlying reasons,
you know,
what parts of the story are relevant to
people and what parts aren't.
So basically what you're going to do is
try not to tell them things they already
know because that would just be
pointless.
And in order to do that,
you more or less have to know what they
know and what they don't know.
And you have to more or less stay on the
edge of that.
But you can do that.
Well,
I might ask you what,
what,
what did you do over the last three
months?
Or I could sAy,
well,
what have you done for the last couple
of years?
And in each case,
you're going to collapse that into some
representation.
Now imagine that the problem you're
trying to solve is what did your culture
do for the last 5,000 years?
Well,
imagine that there are.
There are.
The culture in part is being continually
informed by the individuals that compose
it and they're going to be different
individuals have different stature who
discovered things of different
important.
you know,
when we we often know some people lIke
that.
We know if thomas edison,
for example,
and we can name actual people,
but that's partly because we write
things down in records of can imagine
though that you're trying to represent
your history in a way that you can
remember.
You're going to tell the stories about
people who've done interesting things
because that's what you do.
Even when you tell a story about
yourself.
So imagine you tell one story about
someone who did something interesting
and then you tell another story about
someone else who did something
interesting and so forth,
and that's continually going on.
Let's say in a tribal archaic culture,
and so then what you get is a set of
stories about people doing interesting
things.
Well,
it's easy for that to shift into the
ancestors doing interesting things and
then it's easy for them to shift into
the ancestor doing wonderful things and
that's basically what happens is that
you get the emergence of the culture
story,
which is something like a small set of
culture heroes who've done all the
things that are worth doing and what
you're doing is imitating them and you
know this is,
you know,
your,
your empirical memory of events only
lasts about 100 years,
right?
Because there isn't anyone old enough to
remember anything past that and so what
has to happen is that everything that
happened before that has to be collapsed
into some form that's memorable so that
it can be brought forward and taught.
And that's,
that's how these.
That's the function of these stories,
these stories.
Actually.
It's almost as if the story has
abandoned everything that hasn't stuck
in people's memories and so all that's
left is the most significant is the most
significance because otherwise why would
people bother with it?
They wouldn't tell the story.
They wouldn't be gripped by it,
so okay,
so cyrus,
he's one of these figures.
You could think if,
if you allow people to tell stories
about George Washington,
say in a bleak and an all the semi
mythologized founders of the United
States,
if you allowed people in the absence of
textbooks and writing to tell stories
about those men for the next thousand
years,
maybe what you'd get out of that is an
origin story of the mythic founder of
the state,
and that seems to be what's happened In
the egyptian case with cyrus.
Now he's,
he's a god,
but he's got human characteristics and
so he's also granted the the status of
something that's eternal.
Okay?
Now here's the story of osiris.
Roughly speaking,
he's kind of old now and he's little bit
blind,
but he's blind in a specific way,
and the way that he specifically blind
is that he's willfully blind.
Now,
If you're willfully blind to the
egyptian,
say this straightforwardly,
don't tell you why they believe this.
If you're willfully blind,
there's things that you could know that
you take pains not to know,
and willful blindness under english
common law can be grounds for,
for criminal convictions.
So for example,
if you run a company and you think that
your treasure is cooking the books,
but it's working to your favor and you
decide,
well,
I just won't look.
And then later it comes out,
you can say,
well,
I didn't know.
And people who are prosecuting and say,
yeah,
but you could have known and he took a
conscious choice not to know.
So you're culpable.
And I think that's actually the best
model of friday and repression in the
sentences that it isn't exactly
repression.
It's failure to make the effort to know
something that you could know.
So now sometimes look,
sometimes something terrible happens to
you.
You just can't understand,
but sometimes something terrible is
happening and you refuse to think about
it and because you refuse to think about
it,
you really don't know what it is.
So,
but,
and you mIght say,
well I can't be culpable then because I
don't know what it is,
but you could have known so you're
culpable.
So it's voluntary ignorance and that's
the problem with cyrus.
He was a great guy when he was young,
he was a hero.
He founded the egyptian state,
but you know,
he's not.
Everything could be anymore.
He's got anachronistic and outdated and,
and willfully blind,
which is even worse.
Now there's an idea here.
It's such a bloody brilliant idea.
It's mind boggling.
So I saw her or cyrus is the,
is the state manifested in personified
form and that's reasonable because the
state is like a person.
The person of the state is manifested in
the body of laws.
You guys all imitate that body of laws
and that's what basically makes you
citizens of the state.
You okay?
Good,
good.
So that's what makes you citizens of the
state.
You can all get along because all of you
are imitating the same thing and what
you're imitating is the central body of
custom and law that makes up the state.
That's why you can predict each other.
So that makes you a good citizen.
Now you know,
the problem with being a good citizen is
that sometimes if you're a good citizen,
you're a bad person,
right?
That's a big problem.
So for example,
the better you were at being a nazi,
in all likelihood,
the worst a person you were.
And so that's a,
that's a very useful observation because
one of the things that shows us that
even though it's necessary for you to
imitate the central personality of the
state,
sometimes the central personality with
the state can be pathological.
And the egyptians who established a
quite a lengthy state,
you know,
as opposed to say to the mesopotamians,
the egyptians had been
existing in a complex state apparatus
for a very long period of time.
they started to encounter problems that
were intrinsic to the state.
And remember in the mesopotamian
creation myth,
the primary danger was tire map.
You know,
you make a lot of racket,
you kill appsu that's ordered,
timeout,
comes flooding back and takes you out.
Well,
you can imagine that that would be the
primary story of people in a
civilization that was somewhat fragile.
There are a hell of a lot more worried
about being invaded by the next round of
barbarians are having their crops fail
or being flooded out or something like
that than they are concerned about
whether or not the whole state apparatus
become corrupted is going to collapse.
Now they're partly concerned about that
because remember,
martech is supposed to be.
The emperor is supposed to be being a
good marduk and keeping an eye on
everything,
but the myth,
the mythic structure only talks about
absolute tiny little bit.
They basically say,
don't kill timeouts consort or you'll
make her angry.
Okay.
The egyptians take that lot farther.
They look at,
oh,
cyrus.
And they say,
well,
he was.
There was really something good about
him.
Without him,
we wouldn't even have our state,
so we bloody well better be happy about
that because the state is better than no
state,
you know,
path a lot.
You could say pathological order is
better than absolute chaos.
Now you can have an argument about that,
but whatever.
it's,
you know,
depends on how pathological the order
obviously,
but it isn't that untrammeled chaos is a
good solution.
I think that you can,
and I'm only using this as an example,
you know the americans well and us as
well.
We went into Iraq to take out a person
who is clearly a dictator and who had,
who is a pretty bad guy and who had
really bad sons,
you know,
and his heroes were people like stalin
and hitler.
Well,
they took them out.
Well then what?
Well then all hell broke loose,
you know,
because the theory was you take out the
bad guy at the top and all the good guys
at the bottom get together and instantly
they have a good governments.
Like that isn't what happened at all.
What happened was the whole state
degenerated into chaos and partly out of
that chaos came isis and it's not self
evident that isis is preferable to who
saying least hussein educated,
older women,
you know,
and he was relatively secular.
All things considered.
So I'm not making a case for who's
saying.
My point is,
is that,
you know,
you have to be careful when you disrupt
order,
even if it's pathological because he,
god only knows what's going to spring
forth.
And that doesn't mean that you should
never try to overcome pathological
order,
but it does mean that you should be
very,
very careful.
we need to do so,
you know,
you have to do a micro analysis in some
sense to make sure that you know what
the hell you're doing.
So.
All right,
so anyway,
so why is cyrus?
He's a good guy,
man.
He established the state,
he was awake guy.
He was a hero.
He,
he made order out of chaos and that's
where you live.
So great.
But he's a little old,
a little out of date and he's willfully
blind.
And that's so smart because I think what
the egyptians did,
his cow encapsulate in narrative form
the primary danger of all human
institutions.
There's two of them.
And ellie added talks about this a lot
with regards to flood mythology.
So here's an example.
So there are flood myths all over the
world and there may have even been a
flood.
There's pretty good archeological
evidence for that.
That there was a great flood about
13,000 years ago when a bunch of
comments hit the earth and melted the
north american ice shield,
but we won't get into that,
but doesn't really matter because the
mythological substructure of the story
still has the same meaning regardless of
its historical reality.
So in the biblical story of the flood,
basically what happens is that humanity
is created.
Then they degenerate rapidly and they
get so degenerate,
which is sort of like the elder gods
getting out of hand in the mesopotamian
story that god thinks,
oh to hell with all of you.
You're,
you're a big mistake.
I'm just going to wipe you out.
You know?
But he finds one good guy that's no
nolan,
you know,
out of noah who's like another adam.
In some sense the world is of human
beings is regenerated.
But the idea is,
is that corrupt people get washed away.
So and eliana talks about the flood myth
all over the world or change it and he
says that generally speaking,
there's two reasons why the dante's
flood the planet and what is the system
is old and out of date.
And the second is that people are
corrupt and then if you get the two
things working together,
you get a system that's out of date that
becomes pathological faster because
people are corrupt.
And so I think that you can use the
flooded new orleans is a good example of
that because on the one hand you can
say,
well it was a hurricane,
so that's a natural disaster.
But on the other hand you could say,
well,
people knew the dam dykes were too weak
and they didn't do anything about it.
You know,
they were only built for 100 year storm.
And Louisiana is corrupt beyond belief.
I mean for,
for a democratic state,
it's not corrupt compared to most
states,
but it's really corrupt compared to most
democratic states.
And if you dump money into Louisiana,
it just goes into people's pockets
anyways.
And the infrastructure doesn't get fixed
up.
So then you might ask yourself,
well,
was the flood of consequence of a
natural disaster or the blindness of the
culture?
Well,
you can never tell which of those are
true.
You know,
if you freeze to death in the winter,
is it because it's colder because you're
stupid,
you know,
it's,
there's no difference between those two
things.
So if you get wiped out,
it's because nature comes after you and
because your culture isn't sufficient to
protect you and so you can't separate
those two things.
Okay?
So now the other case that the egyptians
are making,
and this is quite cool,
is that if you take a system that's it's
doing just fine and you just leave it
alone long enough,
it becomes dysfunctional and there's a
bunch of reasons for that.
I mean,
you know,
will,
you imagined that you take your laptop
and it's in perfect working order and
you put it in the closet for 20 years
and you take it out,
what do you have?
It'll still turn on.
Do you have a laptop?
Well,
no.
You know by then it won't even work.
Won't be able to communicate with the
internet.
There won't be any peripherals that can
plug into it.
The software be so outdated that you
won't even know how to use It.
Like it's a brick basically.
And so the point is,
is that,
and you can really see this with
electronic equipment,
a perfectly functional thing maintained
in status of its own accord becomes
dysfunctional.
And so what that means is you have to
run around like a mad hyena,
just keeping your things working.
Now,
of course you know that because like how
much time do you spend in a month
updating your electronics,
you know,
it's just a treadmill of update,
and I think part of the reason that they
haven't contributed much to overall
productivity is because people take all
the time.
They used to waste typing things out on
paper,
trying to keep their,
their,
they're efficient electronics actually
working and you know,
learning all the things you have to
learn and relearning them.
There's this scene in alice in
wonderland,
alice is in underwear,
right?
And she meets the red queen down there.
So that's mother nature and she's always
runnIng around going off with their
heads off with their heads,
which is in an arbitrary way,
which is of course what the red queen
does.
And at one point she tells alice,
it's,
it's such a,
it's such a remarkably deep line.
She says to ellis in my kingdom,
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place.
And that's exactly right.
So you can think the environment that
you're trying to adapt to is that
dynamic content,
intonation of patterns,
and it's transforming across time,
not completely unpredictably,
but certainly not predictably.
And so that means that if you build a
structure that is adapted to it,
that structure has to change and flow in
keeping with the change and flow of the
underlying environment or it gets
outdated,
you know,
it gets,
what do you call that?
Obsolescent.
And so all you have to do Is sit there
and do nothing and you'll become
obsolescent.
And so that's part of the problem with
those cyrus being old.
He was good guy when he was young,
but he's old now.
And the old solutions don't solve the
new problems.
And you could call that a egyptian
existential statement.
All of you have a culture.
It's old,
it doesn't apply or doesn't apply.
Well.
And so what are you going to do with
you?
Throw the whole thing out.
Well,
we know what happens.
The mesopotamians already told us what
happens if you do that.
It's like thai map comes flooding back
and all hell breaks loose so you can't
throw everything away,
but it doesn't work very well.
So it's up to you to figure out how to
fix it.
So okay,
so now.
But now.
Oh sorry,
I've got another problem is you might
say,
well let's say you've got an old
computer.
This by the way,
in case you haven't noticed is a very
old computer and in a way if you keep
tapping on it and upgrading it a little
bit,
you could keep it more or less uptodate.
At some point you're going to have to
throw the whole damn thing away,
but you can do incremental changes to it
on a continual basis.
And the thing will more or less stay
functional.
You can think about those incremental
changes as partial revolutions,
right?
Matt?
Remember that hierarchy now and then you
have to change the operating system.
That sucks because that means everything
underneath virtually has to change,
but more more often you're doing a tweak
here and tweak their,
you know,
at lower,
more specific levels and if you tweak
now often the probability that the whole
thing is going to collapse and that
you'll have to do a clean install is
quite low.
While the same thing applies to the
state logically enough,
this is the state,
right?
If you think your laptop isn't the
state,
then you're not thinking about your
laptop properly.
It's the state,
so when it's going to be more and more
of the state as we progress over the
next 20 years,
you know so.
So you know that if you're aware and you
keep the updates happen,
you stay awake,
that you can keep the thing functioning.
At some point it's going to get so
anachronistic.
It's better just to replace it,
which is also by the way,
what's going to happen to all of you.
Right?
And it's a decision that evolution it in
some sense in biology has made that at
some point trying to keep you updated is
so bloody complicated that you might as
well just get rid of the whole thing and
let something new occurring.
I'm really dead serious about this
because depth evolved.
You know,
you have elements in you that are three
and a half billion years old.
Not everything dies and some,
some creatures are functionally
immortal,
so but no at us.
And the reason is as well,
at some point we just were too old to be
updated.
And so that's the end of that seems to
happen over about a 100 year period.
So anyways,
you can do incremental.
Now imagine you just ignore your
computer completely.
You don't update the thing at all.
Well,
it's going to get anachronistic of its
own accord.
But if you refuse to engage in those
operations,
that would keep it updated,
it's going to get anachronistic a lot
faster.
And that's what happens to a cyrus.
They say the same thing.
It's like he's old and that's part of
the problem.
He's past his prime,
but the worst part of the problem is
that he's willfully blind.
He won't take action even though he
knows it's necessary,
and so he gets out of date and
pathological,
faster than necessary.
Now you know when you hear in the flood
stories that god is angry about the sins
of men,
and that's why he washes everything
away.
It's the same idea.
Now,
the word sin comes from the greek word
hamartia and hamartia is an archery
term,
and to sin means not to hit the center
of the target.
And so basically the idea in the flood
of stories is that if enough people
aren't aiming at the target or hitting
the center,
then things are gonna get so corrupted,
unstable,
that everything is going to get washed
away.
And that's right.
It's exactly perfectly accurate.
So,
which is very,
very cool.
It's very remarkable that that's the
case.
Okay,
so now cyrus,
because this is a myth,
has an evil brother.
Now that's pretty common occurrence.
If you look at the lion king,
which is very much the egyptian creation
myth,
by the way,
the lion king,
the,
uh,
what's the old guy's name now will blind
you remember
he has a brother,
right?
What's his brother scar?
And what's the problem with scar?
He's scarred,
right?
So,
you know,
he's,
he's had,
he says he's,
he's from the bottom of the gene pool
and you know,
he's,
he's been in second place all his life,
but that's not any.
Andy's very,
very intelligent.
He worships his own intelligence.
He regards himself as a higher form of
intellect,
which is very common characteristic of
evil brothers in mythology.
And there's a reason for that.
And he's scarred because life has
scarred him and he's bitter and
resentful and he wants to bring down the
order and he wants to kill the son of
the king.
I mean,
he's a bad guy.
Now the problem is,
is that mufasa underestimates,
and that's exactly what happens to us.
Cyrus cyrus has this brother sat or seth
and I have a sneaking suspicion that r
word set for setting sun is from that
word.
Although I don't know that for sure,
but sounds or are generally,
um,
sounds language remains stable across a
very long period of time and set was
definitely from the egyptian
perspective,
the enemy of the sun.
So that's part of the egyptian cosmology
and the sun is associated with
illumination and brightness and daytime
consciousness and clear apprehension and
vision and all of those things.
And of course the night is opposed to
that unconsciousness and blindness and
danger and all of those things.
So.
So anyway,
seth,
he's pretending to be,
oh,
cyrus's loving brother,
but he's not.
He's plotting to overthrow the first
chance she gets.
And so he's just sitting in the
background feeding him bad advice,
waiting for waiting for him to get weak
enough so that he can strike.
Now the name Set is taken by the
egyptian coptics and turned into satan.
So sap is the precursor of the christian
state.
So you can.
The reason I'm telling you that is so
that you can see how these ideas,
these archetypal ideas of corruption and
evil are are extraordinarily ancient and
they're part of the process whereby
people are trying to figure out what the
right way is to act and what the wrong
way is to act and what the right way is
to set up institutions and what the
wrong way is to set up institutions.
So it's a very,
very long process and it's not something
that someone just sat around and thought
up.
It's way,
way deeper than that.
So anyways.
Oh,
cyrus is being,
you know,
getting weaker and being blind in one
day.
Seth,
thanks.
All right.
Time for action.
So he takes his brother and he chops it
up into little pieces.
Now cyrus is a god,
so you're not going to kill them,
but you can make it very difficult for
him to get his act together.
Now.
So basically what happens is,
oh,
cyrus falls apart.
Now think aBout that.
You fall apart.
People say that the relatIonship fell
apart.
It fell apart.
Things fall apart.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means that a thing is usually a
complex unity of multiple sub entities
and sometimes what holds them together,
the superordinate structure collapses
and all that's left are the things you
know because like when you fall apart,
you don't completely fall apart,
you know,
you're still alive.
What's happened is that the unity of
your psychological structure as being
fragmented and that's a trip to the
underworld,
man.
So you're going to be unhappy.
I broke up with my partner and then I
fell apart.
While everyone knows what that means.
Okay?
So that's what happened to cyrus.
Things fall apart.
So,
so then seth,
being a sneaky sort of character takes
all of those cyrus's pieces and he puts
them all over Egypt.
He hides them in here and there.
So that was cyrus is gonna have a hell
of a time recollecting himself and
getting his act together and coming
back.
And so things fall apart.
Now the same thing happens in the lion
king,
obviously because scar kills us.
So,
so fine.
The insets rules,
that's not a good day for the egyptians.
You remember what happens in the lion
king when scar rules,
the environment becomes completely
devastated because they overhand,
right?
So you get total environmental
devastation.
It's all black and burnt and you know,
nothing is functioning properly and
remember after sin,
but comes back to set things right?
It starts to rain and everything comes
back.
It comes back to life.
Well,
it's another indication of the idea that
you really can't separate the
environment from the culture.
You know,
they're,
they're in a dynamic system of
interaction anyways.
Oh,
cyrus,
things have fallen apart.
Well,
cyrus has a wife.
He has to.
He's king of order.
While we're missing someone,
we're missing the queen of chaos.
We're missing the queen of the
underworld.
That's isis.
Now.
Isis was a long lasting goddess.
There's been goddess religions forever.
There's an idea among
misinformed feminist anthropologists
that the original religious structures
were feminine earth goddess,
tight religions,
and then they were replaced by
patriarchal religious and there's no
historical evidence for that.
And the basket work I know on that is
actually through the unions.
I'm young and Eric Norman,
because what they figured out,
they were kind of on the same track
thinking about the same idea that there
seemed to be a shift between matriarchal
values to patriarchal values and that
that was a historical shift,
but what they found Instead was that
that's actually a mythological idea.
It's not a historical reality and it's
useful as a mythological idea,
but you shouldn't project it backwards
onto time and make it a historical
reality.
So anyways,
isis,
she's been queen of the underworld
forever.
Now,
of course,
when order collapses,
chaos reappears,
and that's what happens.
isis pops up out of the underworld and
her husband's missing and she's not very
happy about that.
So she wanders all over Egypt looking
for his fellas.
And so now that's an interesting idea
because
it touches on like the biology of
innovation in some sense.
So you've heard of the notion of a
seminal idea.
Well,
that's an,
that's a mythologically informed
metaphor.
And so the idea is that in biological
biological reproduction,
semen falls on fertile ground and out of
that something emerges.
Well,
there's a tight analog between that and
what happens in the egyptian myth with
regards to sexuality now young and freud
had a big argument about this because
freud thought you could reduce
everything to sexuality and freud and
freud said that and said,
no,
no.
What you don't understand Is that
sexuality itself is often used as a
symbol for something even more profound
and they didn't agree on that and that's
part of the way they went.
Their separate ways.
You freud was very much unwilling to
believe that religion could be anything
other than a like a set of defensive and
repressive beliefs and practices
designed to protect you from death
anxiety.
That was basically his hypothesis and
and it's wrong.
It's not.
I mean there is that element of course,
because you can use dogs to protect
yourself against all sorts of things you
don't want to think about,
but you can't reduce the whole damn
thing too.
That you want to watch people of any
type that are intellectuals who will
tell you that everything can be reduced
to one cause.
You know,
it's like a misplaced monotheism.
Lots of people do that for marx,
it's economics or class warfare for
freud,
it sexuality,
although he also considers aggression
for foodco its power,
you know,
it's like,
no,
it's not that simple.
You can make a good story out of those
motivations because they're powerful
motivations and they do affect
everything,
but that doesn't mean they cause
everything.
Unit dementia.
okay,
so anyways,
isis pops up.
Can we?
The underworld,
seth takes control.
Chaos emerges from the underworld.
isis wonders around.
She finds it was cyrus says,
fellas,
and she makes herself pregnant.
Well,
so what does that mean?
it means a lot of things.
One thing it means is that if a great
system falls apart,
the parts still have life and you know,
you can think about that.
People often talk about the stability to
the degree that it's stable.
part of the stability of capitalism is
it's creative destruction,
is that capitalism allows great
enterprises to collapse and disperse,
but they don't break down into subatomic
particles,
right?
They collapsed,
but the pieces they collapse into still
has have life.
Some of them more than others.
And then if something collapses,
sometimes part of the thing that
collapsed has enough life to build
something new out of the pieces.
That's the same thing that happens to
you when you go through,
undergo a radical revolutionary
transformation in your character.
You know you might even feel like you're
dying and in some sense the organizing
principles by which you lived are dying.
That's what's taking you out.
And it's,
it's painful.
You know those things are alive.
It's no,
no trivial matter that can be taken
apart.
But you know,
you hope that you get taken apart.
You can find some new information down
there and the chaos,
and that's your union with isis,
roughly speaking and out of that union
of information from the chaos and the
parts of you that are left,
you can come springing back and you
know,
everyone hopes that.
And often it's the case.
You know,
one of the lessons you can derive from
Egypt and mythology is bloody well,
stay awake and make the corrections when
you need to.
Don't be willfully blind because if
you're willfully blind,
you're going to,
you're going to store up chaos because
you're not,
you know,
keeping at bay and then one day when
you're weak,
it's just going to take you out.
And that happens.
That happens to people all the time.
You know,
they,
they let things around them degenerate
back into chaos and then one day their
week and something else comes along to
hit them and they're done.
They can't get up.
It's too heavy,
it's too hard to hit,
and so then they're down in the
underworld and they stay there.
So the general rule is if you're going
to go to the underworld,
it's better to go on purpose and for
short voyages.
And that's the idea behind voluntary
exposure,
right?
Find out what you don't want to look at.
It's easy enough to do that because
you're going to see yourself avoiding
it.
Then figure out how you can approach it
in an order.
Some of it,
you know,
in this big chunks as you can manage and
do that all the time,
stay awake because then you keep your
infrastructure properly maintained and
the probability that you'll be able to
tolerate a powerful blow is much,
much higher.
It's not certain.
That's the other thing about myths.
You know,
they tell you the best way to negotiate
through life,
but they never tell you that that will
work.
They just tell you that that's your best
bet.
And so,
you know,
maybe that's not.
It might be enough.
Okay.
So anyways,
isis finds,
oh,
cyrus's fellas and gets pregnant and
then back to the underworld.
She goes and she goes through her
pregnancy and she gives birth to horace.
Now that's a pretty common story,
right?
That's the long lost.
Rightful king.
King arthur,
for example,
arthur asked to be taken away from the
castle to be raised basically in
isolation.
It's a very,
very common story.
And the reason,
the same thing happens to Harry Potter,
right?
Harry potter is stuck with these
dursleys and you know,
they're just,
they're like every resentful child's
image of their parents,
you know,
so maybe it's more like every resentful
13 year olds image of their parents and
you know,
the truth of the matter is,
is you are a current stock off in a
normative wastelands of your culture.
You know,
you,
you have your specific parents.
They're not archetipal representatives
of reality there.
They're your parents,
their nature and culture,
but in,
in finite and flawed human form.
And what that means in part is you are
raised outside the domain of your
culture.
It's old.
It isn't working very well and it's not
transmitted very well to you.
So you grew up outside of it.
You're alienated from it.
That's that existentially.
But people always felt
existential alienation.
People have always felt alienated from
their damn culture because it's old and
it's sort of blind and there you are,
young and dynamic and full of life and
all it's doing is telling you you can do
this and you can't do that.
You know,
lying to you about some things and doing
it pretty nasty job of others.
And so your own side,
you know when you're alienated from it.
And that's what happens to horace.
He's outside in not world.
That's where he gets bored.
And so that's where thinking about too.
Anyways,
he grows up.
Now horace is an interesting sort of
character.
So you've all seen the image of the
egyptian.
I right.
Everyone knows that image even now,
which is pretty cool.
So it's got a,
an eyebrow and it,
it's got an eye in the middle and then
it's got the iris and usually the pupil
is so big that it covers the whole iris
and there's a variety of reasons for
that.
But one of the reasons is is that that
symbolize interest and attention.
So when you're interested in something,
your pupil grows.
And so horace,
his pupil is really big and he's
checking things out like matt.
So horace is the eye and he's aLso a
falcon.
And you might say,
well why is he a falcon?
And the answer to that is falcons are
birds of prey and they can really see.
So that's another amplification of the
idea of the art.
Now,
falcons fly up above everything,
even above the pyramids and they can see
wherever they want to see.
And so horace is the thing.
That's why he's up above the structures
of mankind in some sense and can see
them panoramic lee.
So he's not encapsulated in any
particular pyramid.
He's the thing that's above all pyramids
and looking and,
and providing you with an overview.
All right,
so and I think the best way to
conceptualize horse in modern terms is
his attention.
That's not thought.
That's a whole different thing.
I get tension is what thought.
Attention is the precursor to thought in
a sense,
attention is where you meet meaning.
That's another way of thinking about it.
You know,
attention is actually where you take
undifferentiated and start to turn it
into order.
And do you think about how much do you
like being paid attention to?
People love that.
Children like you don't pay attention,
then they become pathological.
You don't pay attention to your partner,
your relationship dissolves.
No one pays attention to you.
You crawl off in a corner and die.
Advertisers pay for your attention.
I like attention.
That's a currency.
Now that's value,
so you know,
and you like to be paid attention to
you.
When you do good things,
maybe you'll even do terrible things so
that someone pays attention to you.
Attention is a big deal.
We don't understand it very well,
but anyways,
that the egyptians conceptualized it as
a god not.
So that's smart.
That's a very smart idea.
Anyways,
horace grows up in the underworld and
then you know,
when he gets kind of big and ready to
contend with the world,
he thinks I'm going to take the damn
state back for my eval.
Uncle were all,
that's what you're supposed to do.
You're supposed to grow up,
pay attention,
get yourself the hell out of the
underworld,
and then take your state back from your
evil uncle.
Okay,
so what happened?
So horse,
he gets himself all prepared and he's,
you know,
he's a son of order and chaos,
man.
He's no second grade character.
You remember how many of you have seen
the avengers movies?
Okay.
okay.
So there's,
I think it's Samuel Jackson right now.
Samuel jackson is often in the
background and if I remember correctly,
he's kind of like the mediator between
these shadowy figures that sort of exist
as,
I don't know.
They look,
they all look like middle aged white men
and they're sort of like a power group
and they communicate on screen.
I don't know exactly who they are,
but I'm jackson plays an intermediary,
but he is lacking and I.
And part of the reason you infer that
jackson is locking in eyes because he's
at a pretty long history of being
involved in catastrophe.
And you know,
one consequence of that is that he's
become damaged.
Well,
the same thing happens to horace.
So horace goes back and he says to seth,
I see you for who you are.
I know what you're up to.
You're working for destruction.
You want to take the state apart.
There's nothing positive about what
you're doing.
You facilitate deception.
So I'm taking the state max so they have
a big fight
and during the fight,
seth terrorists out one of horses eyes.
Now that'S we're thinking about too,
because what It means,
and this is exactly right,
you know,
one of the things young set about
encountering malevolence is like let's
say that you wanted to understand what
the nazis did and so you started to take
it apart,
you know,
and at each little bit of exploration
you take it apart a little bit more
deeply and then a little bit more deeply
and then a little bit more deeply,
you want to get to the bottom of it.
Well,
you might ask yourself,
well,
what's at the bottom terrible things?
Well,
the answer to that and answer to that is
the archetype of evil.
And if you are to the degree that you
encountered that,
even if you're capable of god,
like attention,
which is the case of horace,
the probability is that that will be so
devastating and it will destroy half
your consciousness.
That's what happens to horace.
And so like that's another thing I
really like about the myths man there,
they don't mess around like you're
supposed to come out of the underworld.
You're supposed to see what the hell is
going on.
You're supposed to go back and take the
state away from archaic.
It's archaic institutions and willful
blindness.
But if you really contend with that,
you better look out because you're
contending with something that you can
barely master.
Anyways,
horse eat seth,
despite the fact that he has is I tore
an elk.
And so then he tells seth to go outside
the boundaries of the kingdom and to
never come back.
Well,
why doesn't he kill him?
he can't.
He's a garden.
You can't get rid of seth.
Seth is the daddy of the decomposition
of states.
That's not going away.
The best you can do is hold it at bay
for periods of time and you have to be
awake and aware of its constant
presence.
Anyways,
he chased the step away,
but he gets his id back.
And so he,
he reclaims his consciousness from the
malevolent,
from,
from malevolence essentially.
And then you might think,
okay,
well what should you do,
you should slap that.
I back in his head and then you know,
he's defeated evil,
so now he should be king and that would
be a good ending to the story.
But that isn't what the egyptians do
with mrs.
Where they really get brilliant in my
estimation.
So horace takes his art and he goes back
to the underworld.
So he does this voluntarily.
It goes back to the underworld and he
goes back to where was cyrus is existing
because it's sort of the land of the day
I did.
So I.
All.
Cyrus has this weird existence.
He scattered all over Egypt.
But his essence,
I suppose his spirit is down there in
the underworld,
which is,
it's not exactly hell.
Hell is a suburb of the underworld.
Like it's the worst neighborhood of the
underworld.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
You guys go to the underworld fairly
often.
You may take a rare side trip to hell
and you probably regret it,
but.
And we can,
we can talk about what that means
because it actually has a very specific
meaning anyways.
Oh,
sorry.
Resistant inhale.
He's just an underworld.
So he's sitting there sort of,
you know,
inactive and,
and in,
in rough shape.
So horse goes down to the underworld and
he phones finds those cyrus and he gives
him an I.
And so then cyrus can see again,
remember he couldn't see,
he was willfully blind,
right?
And so that's partly what led to his
demise.
So horace gives him this guy that's been
hard fought,
right?
It's the eye with which he encountered
evil.
He gives cyrus that I heard some write
up.
And so then horus and osiris go back to
the surface.
We're old and they unite to form the
ruler of Egypt.
And so the idea is that the proper ruler
is obviously the thing that can pay
attention and conquer the pathology of
the state and willful blindness.
But it's more than that.
It's the thing that does that.
And then rejuvenate's the state and you
know,
one of the things,
I think this is quite interesting.
So,
um,
the hippie culture in the 19 sixties
was,
was a revolutionary culture and you can
make a case that during the sixties and
in the latter part of the fifties that
people,
young people's attention was very much
focused on certain pathological elements
of the state,
know the civil rights movement seem to
be a real thing.
There was a movement towards the
emancIpation of women.
There were lots of things that I think
you can look at from a distance and say,
you know,
good work.
But then there was the other element of
It which was,
well,
you know,
down with the state and don't trust
anyone over 30.
Well that's kind of stupid because first
of all,
you know,
it's not that long until you're 30 and
then what do you do?
And second,
it's like,
well,
no,
you can't throw the damn baby out with
the bathwater.
I mean,
first of all,
you're probably doing that because you
don't want to grow up ever.
you're just peter pan.
And second.
It's like you can't leave ocirus length
with cyrus languishing in the
underworld.
You have to give them vision and bring
them back up to the surface because I
don't care how attentive you are,
if you're also not wise,
you're not going to be good for
anything,
and the wisdom is partly the integration
of the best.
Your culture has to offer you into your
character so that you can be an avatar
of culture and attentive avatar of
culture,
and then you're a well balanced soul.
Well,
so the egyptIans figured all this out
and then it's even cooler than that
because they use this idea of the union
of horus and cyrus as their conceptual
representation of what gave the feral
sovereignty,
which is because again,
like the mesopotamIans,
they were trying to figure out,
well,
what should rule,
you know,
what should be above all,
and the mesopotamians figured,
well,
it's something like marduk.
He's got lots of eyes.
He can talk.
He's brave.
He'll,
he'll conquer the unknown.
He makes things.
As a consequence,
he makes a pretty good talk.
God and the egyptians added a level of
sophistication to that because
horace is not only the thing that will
go into the underworld.
He goes into the underworld,
he rescues things,
have tremendous value,
and then unites with them so that not
only can he see,
but he's wise,
and so then that's what the pharaoh was
supposed to be in.
The egyptians basically characterized
that union as something akin to the
immortal soul.
Now eliana tracks this development.
He called the democratization of osiris.
So first of all,
basically only the pharaoh was allowed
to be the horace.
So cyrus union in some sense,
you know,
so and in,
in a way he was god on earth,
you know,
and which is a conception of course,
that this lasted into cultures for a
very,
very long period of time.
The japanese still thought that way
about their emperor until the end of
world war two.
And many of them still think that way.
So he was the embodiment of divine
sovereignty.
It was in the leader only,
but as the egyptian state developed the
idea that that soul was an attribute
started to descend down the power
hierarchy.
So after awhile the aristocracy started
to use it.
And then now,
and this is a radical
oversimplification,
but it'll do for the,
for the,
for the purposes of this discussion,
you know,
by the time the jews came along and they
come,
it came out of Egypt,
mythologically speaking,
the idea that there could be a,
a,
a union or a relationship between
something that was divided in something
that was individual was distributed a
long ways down the power hierarchy.
No.
And then by the time the greeks showed
up,
well in some sense it was all males,
at least all males who were part of the
polity.
And then when the christians emerged,
it was everyone,
prostitutes,
tax collectors,
thieves,
murderers,
everyone.
and so the idea of sovereignty started
to become,
you know,
first of all,
it was a mythological attribute,
was identified with the ruler,
but then it became a psychological
attribute that was distributed across
the entire population.
It's brilliant.
And as far as I can tell,
that's really those conceptualizations
form,
the substructure of our belief that each
person is divinely valuable.
You know,
in their own right,
that they have inalienable rights.
Even if you're a murderer,
right?
The state is very restricted in what it
can do to you.
Even if you committed a terrible crime.
Even if you admit to it,
the state is still very restricted in
what it's allowed to do with you because
there's an idea that there's something
about you that has the quality of
transcendent value.
That's exactly it and well we know some
of the attributes,
you know,
one of them is the you can see and pay
attention.
The other is that you can speak and
communicate.
The other is that you can become wise,
that you can approach things that
frighten you with courage and generate
new information as a consequence.
Like there's lots of things about you
that the relationship between chaos and
order actually literally dependent and,
aNd that's.
And so the state has come to respect the
individual partly because the individual
is by necessity the thing that
rejuvenates the state.
And so there's this dynamic relationship
between the two.
The state structures you,
but it's old and blind and there's lots
of things that can't see and it's partly
corrupt.
OKay.
But it's a hell of a lot better than
nothing.
Generally speaking,
and so then you're like the forerunner
of the state and you can pay attention
and maybe you can see where things
aren't working exactly right where they
don't working property and fix them,
and so then the state maintains its
protective structure across time and you
exist in a dialectical relationship with
it.
you know,
you see by the time the christian hero
mythology emerges,
christ is more the [inaudible]
constructor of the state than he is the
thing that it encounters chaos,
right?
because a huge chunk of the christian
story is about the antagonism between
him and his culture and,
and the roman culture as well.
So the whole existential drama actually
shifts from,
you know,
hero as buttress against nature,
which of course would have been the case
earlier to hero as thing that decomposes
and reconstructs culture in a radical
way.
So,
you know,
moses does the same things and other and
moses is a master of water.
He's a transformative agent.
So it's an indication of exactly the
same sort of idea.
Well,
it's a good time for a break.